on sait pas le travail à la place des
jeunes ont reçu sur les jeunes qui
créent le jeu vidéo
chaque chose qu'on peut on peut voir ici
il ya tout était programmé pour que ça
va rentrer dans le code puis complice à
ce que ça soit jouable après l'insulté
bien sûr à la demande de plus en plus
puisque on avance il ya toute une gamme
de compétences qui sont développés en
lien avec les programmes au même moment
qu'on faisait le bon jeu justement il y
avait des choses en mathématiques que
j'apprenais sur lui même exactement la
même chose il ya énormément de
compétences qui sont mobilisés qu'il ya
des jeunes qui était toujours seul dans
les corridors qui maintenant ont des
amis
il ya des jeunes qui ne s'exprimait que
peu ou pas et qui maintenant sont
capables de tenir au discours d'un
groupe de jeunes